وصل الرئيس الصيني تشي جين بينج الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في زياره تستمر
حتى التاسع من الشهر الجاري تعتبرها وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه اكبر النشاط دبلوماسي
على نطاق واسع بين الصين والعالم العربي
منذ تاسيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه بالاضافه
الى لقاءته مع العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز وابنه ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان يشارك الرئيس الصيني في
قيمتين خليجيه صينيه وعربيه صينيه بحضور
قاده دول المنطقه تاتي هذه الزياره بينما
تشهد العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه تتوترا
افرا قرار المملكه خفض انتاج النفط من
خلال تحالف اوبك بلس وهو معتبره البيت
الابيض استفافا الى جانب روسيا في حربها
ضد اوكرانيا وهو امر رفضته السعوديه
بين دول المعنيه يجب ان يفضي الى السلام
والاستقرار الاقليمي الولايات المتحده شكل
التحالفات عسكريه مع بعض حلفائها لبث
الانقسام واثاره المواجهه وتقويض السلام
والاستقرار في المنطقه وهو امر منبوس
يكونوا على راس جدول الاعمال خلال هذه
الزياره في ظل ازمه الطاقه التي يعاني
منها العالم نتيجه حرب روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
وخاصه ان السعوديه هي اكبر مصدرا للنف في
العالم والصين هي اكبر مستوردا للنفط
الخام وتشتري ما يقارب ربع الشحنه
السعوديه يتوقع ان يناقش قاده البلدين
ايضا الصفقات المحتمله التي يمكن ان تشهد
خراط الشركات الصينيه بشكل اعمق في
المشاريع الضخمه التي تعتبر محوريه في
رؤيه الامير محمد بن سلمان لتنويع
الاقتصاد السعودي بعيدا عن النفط